¿Sobre qué intervalo "y" de "x" tiene
una razón de cambio promedio de -4?
Entonces la razón de cambio promedio,
si tú piensas en el promedio,
por ejemplo, en esta sección, aquí mismo
la pendiente es muy muy vertical,
luego menos vertical,
aquí menos negativa, menos negativa,
aquí es 0,
luego es positiva, más positiva,
y más positiva y más positiva,
y, cuando llegas a este punto,
puedes ver que estás donde habías comenzado.
Y el promedio,
puedes decir que el cambio promedio,
cambio neto, ha sido 0.
Y en el intervalo
en donde el cambio neto ha sido 0,
también te dice que la razón
de cambio promedio va a ser 0,
entonces,
puedes ver que en la razón de cambio promedio
es realmente la pendiente de la línea,
es la pendiente de la línea
que conecta a los dos puntos finales del intervalo.
Otra manera de preguntar sobre qué intervalo "y" de "x" tiene una razón de cambio promedio de -4 es,
si tú puedes encontrar un intervalo,
el cual la pendiente entre sus dos puntos finales,
es igual a -4.
Así que veamos las opciones que nos han dado,
el primer intervalo es que "x" esté entre -1 y 1.
Entonces, "x" está entre -1,
aquí "x" es igual a -1,
cuando "x" es igual a -1,
"y" de "x" está aquí.
"y" de -1 es igual a 7,
y luego cuando "x" es igual a 1,
cuando "x" es igual a 1,
nuestra gráfica está aquí abajo,
"y" de 1 es igual a -1.
Entonces, ¿cuál es la pendiente de la línea
que conecta a los puntos finales?
Estos dos, estos dos puntos,
¿cuál es la pendiente de la línea
que conecta esos dos puntos?
porque la pendiente de esta línea,
la línea que conecta
los puntos finales de mi intervalo,
esa va a ser, la razón de cambio promedio
sobre este intervalo
y podemos ver claramente que la pendiente aquí,
la razón de cambio de
"y" con respecto a "x" es -4.
Cada vez que nos movemos uno
hacia adelante en la dirección "x"
nos movemos cuatro
hacia abajo en la dirección "y".
Nos movemos
uno hacia adelante en la dirección "x",
nos movemos
cuatro hacia abajo en la dirección "y".
Entonces la razón de cambio promedio
sobre este intervalo es -4.
Así que tenemos que indicar que
este intervalo va a funcionar.